some areas around the house are easy to
clean but it's often the out of sight
jobs that are the hardest one of the
most challenging aspects of deep
cleaning these spaces is the buildup of
grime over time air vents that haven't
been cleaned in roughly half a century
require special tools for example and a
roof that's covered in nearly three
decades of moss calls for a skilled
technician neglecting these spaces can
have consequences the accumulation of
debris in these hard-to-reach areas can
cause structural damage spark fires or
even induce health hazards watch as
eight Specialists share expert tips of
the trade and explain what it takes to
deep clean Decades of household
Grime duct Heroes is an air duct
cleaning company in Illinois many of its
clients have never done a single air
duct cleaning and today's job is no
exception these vents haven't been
cleared of dust and debris for a
century as soon as we walked in we see
the old vents the furnace how old it was
before even opening any of the vents up
I knew how bad it was going to be you
know he said 47 years of dust probably
over a hundred years to be
honest if you look at a vent and you see
dust on the actual vent that's a clear
sign that the ducks have probably never
been cleaned and they're pretty filthy
inside uh we like to start on the very
top of the house and work our way down
that tool that we're using uh we call it
whiskers um the whiskers are just made
out of rubber the end of it attached to
an air compressor and you have air just
coming out through the rod out the
little whisker
[Music]
things so what you're looking at right
now is just me pulling chunks of dust
out that have probably been in there for
over a hundred years there was too much
dust to be putting it in the vacuum um
so I literally went in there with my
hands and grabbed probably like 5 lbs of
dust isn't it gnarly like look at how
much dust that is it's just so sick
[Music]
honestly
this is the back of the dryer uh and you
guys can pretty much see there's an
endless amount of lint coming
out there's a few reasons why you should
get your dryer vent cleaned it's a huge
fire hazard and your clothes will dry
more efficiently it's well worth the
money to just pay to get it cleaned
every
year
[Music]
the vacuum is on throughout the whole
process uh and what we're doing is
blowing all that dust in debris closer
and closer to the
vacuum this house in particular had 18
vents most most of the time I think
probably 75% of the time the houses that
we go to have never been
cleaned um people just don't think about
it you know that getting your air ducts
clean isn't like a regular thought that
comes to your you know head the dust you
typically see in your fence is most of
it is actually uh human skin cells yeah
it's pretty
gnarly
so right now we're done and everything's
pretty much good to go um you're pretty
much going to see a brand new home
honestly uh you're going to feel much
better uh your health is going to be
better I actually got a phone call after
that job and they said all all their
allergies went away it it's just a huge
health benefit honestly uh you might not
notice like the small stuff but you're
body
does moving underground there are the
syid pipes which after heavy use are in
need of significant cleaning and
repairs instead of digging underground
or having to do any demolition to
replace or clean sewage pipes Kenneth CA
cures them from the inside he's a
plumber from Norway who specializes in
pipe
relining this blue tube you're seeing is
being pushed through a faulty sewage
pipe using pressurized air which will
create a tough new pipe inside of the
old
one this technique can be used to fix
cracked leaky or old pipes some signs
that a pipe needs to be inspected
include sewer oders slow drains and
constant clogs pipe relining is a
quicker method compared to Replacements
and it only takes two workers to
complete the
job workers start by inspecting the
inside of the pipe with a tiny camera
they're looking for any cracks or
leaks once they assess the damage
they'll clean the pipe with water in a
rotating
chain this breaks up any caked on Rust
dirt hair sewage and oil inside the pipe
all this buildup shrank the size of the
pipe making it difficult for Waste to
flow through
it now that all that waste has been
removed the pipe is back to its original
size which will allow the new lining to
stick now the relining process begins
the workers measure the pipe and cut a
piece of felt lining to roughly the same
size a vacuum pump sucks out any air
from inside the felt so that it can be
filled with epoxy resin they mix the
resin by hand
[Music]
now that there's no room for air bubbles
which weaken the resin they fill it up
epoxy resin is super strong and
resistant to chemicals it's also a good
choice to prevent roots of trees or
plants from getting in the pipes and
clogging them and since resin starts as
a liquid it can be used to repair pipes
of any
size the team steam flattens the lining
and puts it in a
compressor the compressor uses
pressurized air to shoot the lining into
the old
pipe once it's in there the lining is
inflated so that it sticks to the walls
a new pipe starts to form inside the old
one it cures and hardens for 4 hours
with the help of pressurized air and
heat from a
steamer then the lining is
deflated trimmed and removed leaving
behind a new pipe
inside the pipes can be used as normal
once the job is done and no water will
be able to get in between the liner and
the original pipe
the finished product can last over 50
years which is twice as long as a brand
new PVC
pipe gutters are some of the most
important things to keep clean
especially before
winter I'm Broden and I own a business
in Connecticut called The Gutter Guys
today I'm going to show you how to clean
gutters with wet and dry
debris
[Music]
so when we clean a gutter with wet
debris nine times out of 10 we want to
clean it by hand the reason why is when
it's wet it typically is very muddy and
there's a lot of what we call shingle
dust or grit in the gutters and it's
literally a mud and when we blow them
when they are wet it makes a muddy mess
all over the house we want to clean them
by hand for that
reason so that is a gut but that is
completely jammed with leaves and debris
and the down spout was completely
covered when we released the debris out
of the downspout and got that gutter
cleaned all of that rain water that was
in the gutter just started to flow very
heavily right down the down spout as it
should so often times when we do a
gutter cleaning not only do we find
leaves but we find plants so big that we
actually call them trees sometimes
growing right out of a gutter we're
actually pulling out a big plant and you
can see the whole root system come right
out with
it certain types of trees give off these
little things that come off the tree and
will grow another tree and when those
land in the gutter it's a perfect
environment for that to grow it's a
classic sign that your gutters have not
been cleaned in years it also puts a
significant amount of weight from the
whole root system growing in the gutter
on the gutter which in turn will pull
that gutter off of the facial board
which is actually the board behind the
gutter that the gutter is mounted
to wet debris is usually just saturated
with water water will overflow at The
Gutter and get into your basement and
create cracks in your foundation once
water does find its way into your
basement it reeks
Havoc
here the water that's flowing out of the
down spout at the bottom is the end
result that we are looking for so that
water will flow down and out as it
properly
should when we see dry debris the reason
why that debris is dry is because there
has not been any rain in the past I
would say weak or so so when we clean a
gutter that has dry debris often times
we will use a hand blower and blow those
gutters out because it does a really
good job of just getting everything out
of the gutter whether it be leaves or
sticks or curly stuff that comes off in
the spring depending on the pitch of the
roof we will get on that roof start our
hand blower and walk across that roof
line hand blowing out all of the debris
out of that
gutter sometimes the debris is very
Compact and it's thick That's a classic
sign of maybe a couple of years that
somebody had not had their guts
cleaned we stick to one type of ladder
and that's an aluminum ladder the
aluminum ladder does conduct electricity
so it's very important we stay away from
power lines when we are moving aluminum
ladders we could get severely
electrocuted it's certainly deadly which
is why we Mark the power line areas with
flags before we start a gutter cleaning
because you're looking where you're
walking so you don't look up to see the
power lines so it's very important for
us to have a reminder that power lines
are there we we will often drop a penny
down the down spout just to know that
that down spouts free and clear because
we can see and hear it go all the way
through and back out at the bottom and
we know that we're in good
shape the best advice I can give a
homeowner is to be proactive and not
reactive typically when you're reactive
it's too late damage has been done the
water may already be in your basement it
may already be in your home and it's
just not a good way to maintain your
house water is seriously detrimental to
your house and the main cause of water
is from your gutters so if you keep the
gutters free and clear and you do
consistent cleaning whether it be two or
three times per year which we recommend
you will never have any issues with
water in your basement or ruining your
flower beds or rotting out the fascia
and sofits of your home just stay on top
of gutter
cleaning but perhaps even worse than a
clogged gutter full of leaves is a pool
that hasn't been cleaned for 6 years
watch as miles Laflin cleans out one of
the dirtiest pools he's ever seen all
right then had a DM come through can I
help sort out this pool which actually
looks more like a pond I know I was half
expecting to see a fish swimming around
in the bottom there was plants growing
in there like pond plants they thought
maybe like like when they were cutting
the grass and they had the doors open
maybe little bits BW in and like seeds
or whatever just went into the water and
see bits start growing and stuff so
maybe like that but who knows we're
going to empty it and clean out dropping
in the submersible pump first and we'll
be back the next day nice and empty but
not nice and
clean time to get to work I'm going to
jump in have a look at the damage
first yeah so once the pole was empty um
we brushed them into a corner of a m
with a big brush um shoved them out into
a bucket and threw it on their compost
heat the main difference between
cleaning an indoor and an outdoor pool
is normally you don't get any sort of
debris in a indoor pool obviously this
one had plants growing in it took about
five five or six years for this pool to
get like that but for an outdoor pool
that' probably only take maybe a year
year and a half for it to get like that
state so before we emptied the pool this
was actually floating so when we emptied
it it sort of like the plants had like
started attaching themselves to the
wall then Jet washing the walls on the
floor quickly have a guess at what pitch
was tiled in on the floor I went for a
dolphin turns out it's a sea lion that's
pretty cool
though come coming up nicely but there's
still some stains left over so what
we're going to do is mix up some acid in
a bucket of
water scrub that all over the floor and
walls then we're going to jet wash the
around jump back in the pool rinse that
down get the big Hoover Out start
hoovering up all the last little
[Music]
bits
um so that is a chlorine dispenser and
you can fill that up with the chlorine
tablets and it slowly dissolves the
tablets feeding chlorine into the
pole
you could fill up the chlorine feeder
with the tablets but it won't give your
P instant chlorine you'd then put in the
granules to give it that
initial chlorine dose and then the
tablets will slowly dissolve bringing up
the chlorine level as
well that is um well some people think
it's me adding color to the
pool is that what makes the pole look
blue is what some people me message me
um but actually it's
algicide and that is to prevent um the
growth of
algae uh so that is a jelly Cube and
it's a water
clarifier also it removes phosphates
from the pool um and helps with chemical
efficiency what it does is help with
like a layer pick up small parts
particles therefore making the pole bit
clearer when you initially put salt in a
pole a freshly filled pole it will take
around a week for the salt to be
generated into chlorine itself and the
process is called
electrolysis
it looked as if it had just been
finished from like new build the tiles
were like nice and blue nice and white
tiles very clean
looking um 100 times better than what it
did when I turned up this was all within
maybe half a day's work I I've seen
green indoor pools but never an indoor
pool with anything growing other than a
little bit of
algae a home's exterior is best cleaned
with a good power washer my name is AJ
jiner owner of advanced pressure washing
LLC today we're going to show you how we
clean the exterior of a client's dirty
home step by
step we in general we offer exterior
cleaning but the main services in the
residential field are house washing
gutter cleanout uh concrete cleaning
those are the main ticket items that we
solicit to the residential clients
[Music]
the condition of the fence structurally
is great but as you can see it's covered
in build an algae wood is very
particular because if you uh use too
much pressure you're going to cause a
lot of damage to the surface so to treat
it we just use water we actually use
moderate pressure we make sure always to
go with the grain this keeps us from
furing SL damaging the
wood
[Music]
the driveway is terrible covered in
mildew and algae the chemicals we
normally use is called sodium hypoc
chloride 12.5% or better known as pull
shock SL industrial bleach uh we
normally delete that down to 50/50 ratio
in our buckets this kills a mil algae
that top layer when we pre-treat it
kills it almost
[Music]
instantly this is called a whisper wash
Big Boy Surface Cleaner that metal
tubing uh actually rotates a round on a
swivel that's the item that that I use
to actually clean
[Music]
concrete
from there we'll actually go around
washing the trim of around the brick and
other areas the Surface Cleaner couldn't
reach uh and then we will post treat
with a detergent again to get any
organic stains that are left
[Music]
behind uh after we do the driveway we'll
then do the uh front patio and sidewalk
uh ALS so sometimes if the client wants
we'll also do the curbs along the
[Music]
drive
the house is in pretty good condition
but there was a few spots that we
noticed that were pretty bad with heavy
and thick mildew analy uh on a house we
use roughly about 10% sodium
hypochlorite uh mixed with about 90%
water so the black on the brick is
actually mil just really thick mil and
algae uh this is caused by moisture uh
and shade allowing for such big build do
an algae to
[Music]
grow when we wash a house's exterior we
wash the roof the outside of the gutters
the side of the home the windows the
doors anything that on the side or
attached to the home
itself
[Music]
so we're finished we finally got the job
done uh so roughly this job took us
about uh 4 and 1/2 hours everything
looks amazing the client was beyond
happy with the job that we have done you
clearly see everything is transformed
into a new clean state my personal
suggestion instead of trying to do it
yourself is always hire a professional
because you're dealing with some very
strong and dangerous chemicals uh and it
can become dangerous when in the hands
of someone not
experienced next up Sid Partridge of
Partridge exterior cleaning in the UK
walks us through what it takes to remove
moss from a roof that hasn't been
touched in nearly three
decades here I'm beginning to scrape the
roof so I'm trying to remove as much
Moss as possible this is what I'll be
doing for the bulk of the day and this
is the hardest part of the job I have
the tool that I use it's basically a
flat Metal Blade angled to one side
which means I can get the edge of the
tile which usually carries a lot of the
Moss and scrape the bulk surface of the
tile at the same time I use sort of a
side to side motion and it is very
taxing on the body so it takes a long
time to build up the endurance and
strength to do it so on this roof you'll
see a lot of brown and green this is the
m you see a lot of white spots people
think is bird droppings but this is
white Lin Moss is terrible for roofing
and roof materials especially in the UK
as we get a lot of damp weather over
here so it just tends to grow and fester
more and it will grow in between the
cracks of the tiles now when you have
hot weather turn into cold weather the
mus will freeze and expand and then end
up cracking the roof tiles which can
create holes leaks and things like that
in the roof so this part of the job
where I'm on the scaffolding was the
hardest so I used a 40 ft extendable
pole with the scraper attached on the
end and I was almost at Max extension so
the scraper itself is quite heavy and
the pole itself is quite heavy so having
that out at a near horizontal level for
a couple of hours is very difficult and
as soon as this was done I was relieved
and happy to move on to the next part so
what I'm cleaning here is a four
bedroomed house it's got big flat
concrete tiles so these are some of the
best tiles to come across to clean the
surface s of them and because they're
completely flat it's very easy to get
the Moss off you do not get RS better
than this so it's rare that you'll
actually get away with using a broom to
clean a roof as usually the Moss is very
very stuck on and it's typically just
used for cleaning up however on this job
the Moss was coming off easy so in
certain sections it can just be easier
just to try and sweep off a majority and
then sort of fine tune it with a
scraper so the typical cleaning
chemicals that I use in my roof cleaning
work is a chemical called a bioside uh
what this essentially will do is destroy
any of the organic growth left on the
roof and it has a residual cleaning
effect once I'm gone as well so there's
no rinse in it after you leave it on the
roof to fully dry and soak into the
tiles this will get anything that we
can't get to by scraping so anything
that's left in the gaps any sort of
really stubborn stains and marks that
are left on the tiles also will slowly
degrade so the brush that I'm using here
is a basic waterfed pole that most
window cleaners would use that's all you
need it's got four jets in it which will
fire out the chemical mixed with the
water onto the roof and the brush is
just used to agitate that chemical which
will help it foam up as you can see this
helps it stick to the roof more as it's
a natural surfactant so what I'm doing
here is I'm applying the bide solution
to the roof now this is diluted at 25 to
1 with water so for every 1 liter of
bioside I use 25 L of water to dilute it
ensuring I'm covering every square inch
of this roof making sure it's completely
soaked in a lot of mistakes people make
is not putting enough on and they're
left with a very patchy roof so it's
really important to get complete
coverage and make sure all of the tiny
little gaps are completely soaked so if
you don't fill all of the gaps on the
roof with the chemical then the M will
regrow with a Vengeance the important
part is making sure anything organic on
this roof is completely absorbing this
chemical so once the bioside completely
soaks and dries in you would never even
know it was on there and your results
will start to come after a few weeks the
main thing is trusting in the chemical
because it definitely will do its job
so it's important to have your roof
cleaned because the buildup of M will
over time damage the tiles on the roof
which can lead to cracks damp leak all
sorts of issues in your home that you
really don't want happening and if the
problem is not treated early enough then
it can lead to very expensive roof
repairs in the future as far as time
scale on how often should my roof be
cleaned it is pretty much a onetime deal
for the majority of the process process
as long as it's being kept on top of and
in future it would just be a light
chemical treatment just to keep anything
up Bay so the first step is getting it
done and then it's a case of maintaining
it even the household appliances we use
to keep things neat like washing
machines need to be cleaned back inside
the home we see what it takes to remove
the buildup of detergent and softener
that can wear down machines if not clean
properly hi I'm drick Dennis I
specialize in repairing and cleaning
washing machines dryers any major
appliances the two main types of washing
machines that I work on are top loaders
and front loaders I'm going to show you
how I clean
them so this topload washer is I would
say between 15 and 17 years old this
machine here hasn't been cleaned I would
say ever since it was purchased the
biggest problem with this the abundance
of buildup from you know excessive of
use of detergent fabric softener all the
buildup you see that's what causes this
big ring around the top the water
doesn't come up that high that's why you
see the different levels and then you
know the buildup of mold the perfect
ideal circumstance for for mold and
mildew buildup is moisture darkness and
heat so common buildup in these machines
due to overuse of high efficiency
detergent and fabric softener which you
don't need this big buildup you're going
to get rust you're going to get mold
mildew two table spoons of high
efficiency detergent and no fabric
softener will make your machine last
ages longer than if you're dumping a cup
or two of fabric softener it doesn't get
your clothes any cleaner I highly
recommend cutting out fabric softener in
your laundry regimen the reason that I'm
so against fabric softener is when you
use fabric softener the reason that it
works is the reason that it's bad so it
builds up like an oily residue because
those enzymes have been trapped inside
your shirt and so that's what causes it
to smell so it's not because of you but
eventually the overuse of high
efficiency detergent and Fab softener
will cause your clothes to smell even if
they're clean so anytime we maintenance
the machine we want to make sure that
we're unplugging it from any power
source and it's good to cut the water
off so generally we start from top to
the bottom the main thing is removing
the tub and cleaning the inner and outer
baskets that's where all of your smell
comes
from with these direct drive machines a
lot of times we have the legs are Rusty
and we either scrape them down and
repaint them make sure we knock the
cobwebs out all that kind of stuff
sometimes we'll find a little baby stock
you never know we like to use
toothbrushes different um different
style brushes you have pointy brushes
flat brushes they all have different
jobs but brushes are are are very key
they're vital to everything we do so the
brushes really helped to get in there
and you know kind of get in the corners
and the crevices to clean all this mil
and mold
out sometimes the pressure washer
doesn't get inside the balance string
and we have to some bristles in there
and kind of really put some elbow grease
in it my favorite cleaner is pinea
bleach Lysol vinegar is more of what I
recommend for people to use through a
washing cycle white distilled vinegar
has AIC compounds that help kill some
bacterias when we pressure wash first we
start the outside we can get a lot
better into the balance ring a pressure
washer the water Finds Its ways into all
the crevices and it does a much better
job at pushing out all this mold and
mildew and detergent buildup and fabric
softener build up all the way out the
holes and we can just rinse it out of
the inside and we have pretty much a
brand new basket so the steam cleaning
comes usually comes after the pressure
washing just because we want to get kind
of a final clean the best thing about
the steamer is you know the water comes
out at super high temperature and that
helps to effectively sanitize any of
these crevices or cracks or anything
that we can't just clean with a pressure
washer or bleach
so with the front loader the cleaning
process it's similar but it's a lot
different in the disassembly and just
the orientation of the basket I can't
remove a basket all the way from a front
loader I can only clean the front half
the old school top loaders are built
like tanks the front loaders are not but
they clean your clothes better they
generally don't need as much cleaning as
a top loader because of the orientation
and the way the water uh spins inside
and the water actually keeps the tubs
cleaner uh the biggest part of the smell
that we see is from pump building up
lint and debris in there and people not
clean it out and then you stay with a
smell or because people don't wipe out
their uh their door seal every time they
use the machine they keep the door
closed and then that just builds up a
Milo smell as long as you keep the door
open and and wipe the door seal out and
you know run a washing a washer cleaner
tablet through once a month or so white
distilled vinegar it's not going to
smell I can guarantee it so with this
front loader it actually has a cleanout
spot for the lint this is what protects
your pump and this is what keeps helps
keep the smell down internally pull the
door down we drain the water out of this
little this is a drain hose that
actually pulls whatever water is left
inside the pump and then we take the
filter out clean it out and that's it
it's that simple I recommend doing this
every 30 days at least every 6 months
and this is going to prevent odor it's
going to keep the it's going to keep
your washing machine lasting a whole lot
longer the average lifespan of pretty
much any washer is 2 and three years
before the bearings go out you know just
because of and that really comes from
the overuse of of detergent so when a
detergent breaks down that oil and
grease it'll cause the bearings to get
rusted Rusty and then your washing
machine will sound like a jet plane
taken off that's bad bearings it's
really hard to get to if you can't
physically tear these things down and
clean them yourself so the best thing to
do is preventive maintenance two
tablespoons of detergent no fabric
softener at all but if you have to use
it make sure you dilute it by 50% you
know when I sell a machine to somebody I
want them to have the faith that I have
sold them the cleanest used wash machine
that they can possibly
buy finally we have the draw events
these can become packed with lint and
dust with regular use over time here's
how the professionals tackle the job my
name is Aaron cotton and I am the owner
and operator of dry vent superheroes of
New Orleans my name is Sophia Jano Scott
I am the co-owner and business manager
of dry event superheroes of New
Orleans today we're going to look at how
to clean out a Dusty dryer vent the main
thing that gets basically conglomerated
in the vent pipes is a lot of either
dead skin cells pet hair children's
glitter regular hair just dust dry
detergent anything that can stay and
stick on our clothes that can come off
in the
wash the worst is always going to be any
pet clinics you're cleaning towels daily
and you're not just cleaning towels but
you're cleaning towels full of pet hair
which is usually thicker and coarser and
sometimes more oily than um human hair
the metal brush not only breaks it up
but it kind of catches as well so it
caught all that hair and you can see as
I pull it out it's just almost a whole
dog that it seems like I pull out it was
literally just mounds of hardened pet
hair and lint inside all the way to the
exit and then that exit had about 4 feet
of bird's nest just compacted at that
end because there was no vent cover on
the end it was just an open tube so took
us about two hours to clean the vent in
entirety get everything out we scoped it
with our little camera about six times
trying to make sure we got every little
piece out of
[Music]
there as the lint just gets stuck in
there and it builds over time the Heat
can't get out so the heat just stays
there and and accumulates right there
and it condenses and that's actually how
a fire will
started part of our inspection when we
first go in is to make sure is this vent
connected within the wall we only use
these types of vents they are metal but
also flexible but they're the only type
of connection hose vents that can
actually contain a fire as opposed to
the foil vents if you look on the back
of your dryer most dryers will say don't
use a foil vent and most people just
don't read that warning we get behind
the dryer and we take the metal tube
that's behind the dryer and we take it
off and we inspect to make sure that uh
the inside is either dirty or clean
because you either want to clean it out
or replace it
the Second Step would be to put our rods
with the brushes into the wall with the
camera we can see inside the wall of
what's going on and the customer can see
as well of either how dirty or how clean
it is you can definitely tell almost how
long it's been because if it's only been
like a year or two maybe like a little
or nothing at all but when we're getting
to like the three to 5 years or plus
you're getting literal mounds of stuff
that's coming out you know it's almost
like from a mole hill to mountain of
stuff that you're getting out and you're
like wow it gets really gross if it's if
it's 10 plus
years so after we inspect it and see how
dirty it is then we take our brushes
with our rods so that goes inside the
wall and our drill basically just cleans
everything
out we call this the vent polisher brush
it has this metal teeth at the end so
when that goes through your vent that's
going to polish your vents as well as
clean it so it's going to make it even
harder for lint to stick in the
future when we take our helpet filter
vacuum cleaner we make sure that no dust
gets in the air for either us or the
customer to breathe
in no Cleaning Solutions or chemicals
just the the brushes and the HEPA filter
back and cleaner really does the
job and then once all that's done and
clean we turn towards the inside of the
dryers we uh get all the length that
might have be stuck in there we uh go
back and we take our aluminum tube here
and we put everything back from the wall
to the dryer we do use heat safe tape on
all of our repairs or connection hoses
we do also use clamps the reason why we
use both is because you want your dryer
vent to be able to be unhooked every
year and cleaned and we push the dryer
back and then we check under the lint
trap we definitely found a lot of weird
stuff coming from the dryers especially
under the lint trap I've had one
employee as we were cleaning he pulled
out a whole silver chain I found money
uh like $5 and a couple $1 bills and
then of course we get the not so fun
stuff bird eggs and wasp nest that's
usually towards the outside of the house
not like in the dryer itself also storm
damage whenever we have a bad storm
hurricane and um something gets impacted
in the vent or the roof comes off or
something you're probably going to get
water in your vent in which case you
need a professional to come and take
that out cuz it's going to be really
nasty water mixed in with all that
land so you've had uh multiple customers
tell us I've been in this house for over
10 years I haven't even thought about
cleaning it out and they're like why are
my clothes still wet a lot of the times
it's not your dryer it's in fact that
the line is just clogged up with all the
lint and hair and everything the most
important thing to do with keeping up
your Dyan is definitely to get that
annual professional cleaning but um in
addition to that cleaning your lint trap
with every use is the biggest
one I would say the most satisfying is
leaving with the customers all happy and
smiling and knowing that they're safe uh
that their house is safe and that their
product is going to work as they want it
to